[Musique]
il révèle effectivement là la profondeur
du malaise qui est dix nouveaux deux
professions qui a beaucoup évolué et
dans des conditions d'exercice sont
énormément dégrader au cours des
dernières la crise sanitaire est inspiré
la situation d'autant plus compliquée
mais ce n'est effectivement que un
phénomène qui accents qu un mouvement de
fond que nous avons malheureusement
constaté
[Musique]
vous m'avez demandé les chiffres des
démissions à l'éducation nationale donc
elles ne sont pas particulièrement aux
sons dans le premier degré la
considération elle passe par la
rémunération elle passe par d'autres
facteurs comme vous le savez nous nous y
sommes attelés au travers du grenelle je
suis optimiste sur notre capacité nous
la france au 21ème siècle et cours de la
décennie qui vient a revalorisé
complètement le professeur dans la
société
[Musique]